i love it
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby and i will be your driver on this
journey uh tonight as the youtube title
says uh i'm going over some of the worst
games i've played in recent memory
thankfully
i've had pretty good results in recent
memories so my worst games even though
they they do look bad when you dig into
the actual moves the results haven't
quite been been as bad but to live up to
the title i want to look at this game
that i recently played against the one
and only julian prolego st louis native
uh in the recent master lab tournament
which i already briefly covered some of
the games from so this was my only loss
from the tournament and it was the kind
of loss where the immediately after you
play it you're like oh that was just
dumb there's not much to learn from here
but as always there is almost always
something to learn from in your games
and so i want to talk tonight about how
to look at games that are somewhat
painful games that you feel like you
know you lost for a dumb reason and how
to still find you know something to
learn from from them
so this is it uh you guys get to see me
at my worst here tonight uh let's let's
take a look
so julian played one e4 and julian's the
kind of guy who
uh depending on who he's playing will
mix things up he plays all three of
these moves now and i really had no idea
what he had prepped for me so i was
planning just to play my repertoire and
face the challenges as they came so i
normally play the keracon so i start
with c6 we get d4 d5 he chooses knight
to d2
going for the quote unquote classical
variations which happen after dtake e4
knight take e4
bishop f5 knight g3 and bishop g6
so who can tell me the normal ideas of
this particular opening line uh why has
black done the things that black has
done why has white done the things that
white has done what's what's the point
of it all
yeah brian
i mean um
um
absolutely so the idea of the carrot con
it's actually a very ambitious opening
is that we are not content to play like
french players and
uh sort of hole up leave our bishop on
c8 we want to immediately get this
bishop outside of the pawn chain where
it can be active and it can sort of
counter the opponent's bishop uh but in
order to do this we do have to give
something back you know chess is game of
give and take so of course in the carol
con the thing that we have to give back
is number one this little bit of central
space white has this pawn in the center
we're not going to be able to challenge
it for a little while
and number two the bishop although it's
active outside the pawn chain as always
in the opening if you bring your bishops
out too early they can sort of fall
victim to uh the the opponent's pieces
they they're a little bit vulnerable
easy to attack you know they're long
range pieces um and so for example the
bishop on c1 is already doing a great
job on c1
but when they sort of come out come near
the enemy pieces they oftentimes will be
pushed around and this is why the main
move here is actually h4 this bishop is
close to getting trapped on g6 if i
pretend nothing's going on it will get
trapped
and so normal opening lines will will go
something like this white gains some
time against this bishop uses that time
to gain this kingside space and there's
a number of ways that the game can go
but oftentimes white tries to castle
queen side push the g pawn sort of
attack on the king's side these are the
normal plans
um so here we are you know i'm
comfortably aware of the normal ideas as
is julian and he chooses to play this
move knight g1 knight 1 to e2
which is a move i've seen before it's
got a slightly different idea
actually it's a similar idea but a
slightly different way of going about it
rather than leading with h4 h5
white is trying to put this knight on f4
challenge this bishop with the knight
and maybe then follow up with this move
h4
so i always play this move e6 in
response
we see knight f4 and now bishop d6
and here the only moves i was really
familiar with were uh i think c3
or h4 uh both of which are uh just sort
of more well-known opening lines
uh the idea of h4 now with the knight on
f4 is that obviously what's going to
happen if we try to do the same thing
and play h6 white has an extra option
here
that sort of just blows up black's
position
yeah brian um
you just take the bishop this is the
whole point of white's opening is that
now h4 is a threat and you cannot
respond to that threat with h6 so this
is the idea
for white and i you know already knew
the antidote i like to think i know
something about the keracon
so in response to h4 black can play this
nice move queen to c7
and the point now is that if you come
after my bishop you are actually leaving
your knight behind and i'm not sure the
exact correct way to do things i suspect
you should take here and then take on f4
so you get the piece back and uh upon as
well if white were to to go for
something like this
and the idea of c3 is to combat this
with something like queen f3
and then after we continue developing uh
believe it or not in this sort of crazy
line after h5
black is going to play this move bishop
c2
because it's the only safe square on the
board but it does turn out to be a safe
square uh so things can get pretty crazy
uh instead julian played a move that i
was not familiar with which was uh
knight g to h5
and
julian very well prepared guy
works hard on chess and knows my
repertoire very well so he's able to
find a hole in my repertoire he succeeds
in winning the opening battle in that
sense
so the question is now uh what do you do
you've been surprised in the opening you
haven't seen this move knight g to h5
yet uh how how do you approach this in
in your games
um so take a second look at this
position in particular see if you can
come up with some options and i'll talk
a little bit about the thought process
so obviously just to get you started
white is making a threat so we've got a
problem to solve
hello hello welcome thanks for joining
so do any candidate moves spring to mind
after seeing this move knight gh5
so the good news is i know i'm not
busted here um hi come on in
just just grab a seat
uh the good news is i know i'm not
busted here because i know my openings
well enough to know that's okay i
haven't really done anything wrong i
should be okay
what do you think brian
bishop back to f8 yeah so
no um
just uh
you can sort of
outside of chess you can you can kind of
do do some logic here and realize that
bishop f8 is just never going to be the
move and the reason for that
is
uh in this position
if i have a better move than bishop d6
then you know i'm gonna wanna play that
and so
here if i go bishop f8 and white does
anything else uh my best move is still
gonna you know i i'm gonna need to
develop this bishop at some point i
can't leave this bishop on f8 forever
um
and something like h4 knight f6 knight
g3 we've actually now transposed to what
would have happened here
so it's like
i can't really bring this bishop back
because i know that then i'll end up
playing an inferior move and at best
transposing you know maybe bad things
happen to me as well after bishop back
to f8 maybe white can do something else
but i think the simple move h4 is is
already enough when
again i don't see anything besides
something like knight f6 it would just
be transposing to a worse line
but you've got the right idea we need to
do something about g7 obviously so
there's really only
uh
three
options that i was able to to come up
with here
so yeah move the king king f8 uh that is
absolutely one of the options i i came
up with
um by the way it did anybody consider
this move knight to f6 sort of a tricky
move
nobody
yes
not yet okay so knight f6 is actually
really desirable because if the knight
cannot or if the knight takes on g7
maybe i go king f8
and you've sort of got a problem with
with your knight being stuck
on the side of the board and who sees
the idea in this position
if i actually could get this then this
would be amazing i just win here
yeah so it'd be nice to remove the
defender but unfortunately
uh white can also capture with the
knight and remove that from from danger
as well
but this one's a little bit simpler yeah
brian
yeah this is simply a double attack um
it's a pretty long range double attack
but but it does work out whoops spoilers
you didn't see anything um so we're here
um now obviously knight f6 has a problem
and that problem is that white has a
much better move after king f8 here than
knight h5 uh and that's just very
unfortunate for me so one more tactic
for you guys to find
go ahead and just shout it out if you
see it
yeah either knight takes on e6 and when
i take back it gets replaced by the
other knight and i lose a queen so
unfortunately for me knight f6 is no
good which leaves me really with king f8
as an option
or capturing one of the knights is is
the only other thing i can really do
so
uh the bad news for me i got surprised
in the opening king f8 definitely looks
a little bit risky if you don't know
what you're doing right you give up
castling rights
your kin gets stuck in potentially the
center you're going to have to work hard
to develop your rook on h8
so not really what i what i want to do
um
yeah do you have something
yeah uh so which bishop and which knight
this one
yeah so i wasn't really in love with
with this one to be honest because in
the carrot con like i said you know it's
great to get this bishop outside the
pawn chain but it is also going to be
vulnerable here so after bishop f4
knight f4
uh black is actually gonna have a lot of
the same problems as before h4 h5 is
still sort of coming
bishop is just not so comfortable here
so for that reason i ended up capturing
on h5
white takes back with the knight and now
i am able to play this move g6 in this
instance you actually cannot go knight
g7 because king f8 would win the knight
you know you no longer have this knight
takes e6 garbage because your other
knight is is now missing
so
i kept it simple and i think that's
important to do so far i i really don't
mind how i played this game at all you
want to keep things simple when you get
surprised in the opening you want to
stick with good solid moves and that's
what i did
um so julian retreats the knight back to
f4
i develop out now with knight to e7
which looks a little bit odd it might
make sense to go to f6 and i think
knight f6 is fine but my idea was simply
that i wanted to put a little bit of
pressure on this d pawn while he
developed
white played g3 i went knight f5
bishop g2
and then
what do you think about the move castles
here good idea or bad idea
these are all the subtle little
decisions that that get made in the
opening
yeah so in the opening white has sort of
provoked some some weaknesses over here
right so you do just have to be a little
bit careful as you were saying now i
don't think um
i don't think white's gonna sacrifice
right away
um but these are definitely ideas you
have to keep uh keep in mind
but really there is one plan in
particular that just looks sort of very
very frightening for black to deal with
here
um
and specifically i think it's so
frightening because white hasn't castled
yet so we might get into
into some danger
so i've talked about this in a lot of
previous lectures but whenever one of
the pawns in front of your king gets
disturbed and has to move uh it often
creates what i like to call a hook
or not just me a lot of people call it a
hook
so why is it called a hook well it's
something that white can latch onto
to open files and open up
lines files or diagonals into uh into
your king's position
so g6 is going to act as a hook here and
white can latch onto it somehow
so with that in mind what what move do
you think might happen
yeah of course h4 uh specifically
because this rook is still on h1 white
hasn't committed to castling yet um and
h5 is going to be a very very serious
threat if i just ignore this and i allow
h5 to happen of course i'm going to be
running into some some big threats here
i might have to try something like g5
which is not really something i'm
interested in doing if i continue
ignoring things uh play a semi-defensive
move like queen f6
takes takes
and i have a lot to be a lot to be
worried about coming down the h file
i might not be losing right away but
it's certainly not going to be very very
comfortable for me uh with these pieces
sort of sort of looming i mean
you know maybe white has to take some
time to play something like c3 but just
statically there's a lot that's wrong
with my position that i don't really see
a way to fix so
it's important to not play moves
automatically after you've been
surprised in the opening because castles
is sort of an automatic move that you
just expect to make but it's very easy
to sort of slip uh slip into treble if
you're not totally familiar with the
position
so with all of this in mind i developed
the knight first which is a very subtle
difference it's not a big difference but
it might have made a big difference in
the game because i i don't think i would
have been very happy at all after h4
uh so knight to d7 my opponent has
thankfully run out of useful moves and
castles the king so now this is my my
green light to go ahead and castle as
well um
not nearly as worried about stuff like
h4h5
because i can respond to this with h5
and with the rook on h1 i'm gonna have
to worry about stuff like like g4 but
with the king on g1 g4 does more harm
than good to white's position i'm going
to be able to do things like take on h4
and get a lot of counter play
so h4 of course is not played by my
opponent now instead he chooses just c3
to help solidify this pawn
um and now i need to come up with a plan
to
try to equalize the game so i sort of
survived the opening i didn't you know
lose a pawn didn't get my king's
position wrecked but i'm definitely not
equal here uh as always in the caro con
as long as your opponent has this
nagging space advantage you're gonna be
a little bit worse until you can do
something about it uh beyond that my
opponent has managed to snag my light
squared bishop and the bishop pair so i
have a lot of work to do here so now
it's time to sit back and say okay you
know things didn't go uh perfectly but
it's not a disaster so how am i going to
to equalize this game how am i going to
get my pieces involved and make sure i'm
not
not a lot worse
so this is where it helps to be familiar
with the carrot positions but i'll give
you a hint there's two big pawn breaks
you should be thinking about
so
um yeah so the youtube chat has some
ideas
any ideas here before i give away the
answer
go ahead and just shout them out if
you've got them how can we deal with
this the space advantage for white
okay of course we need to challenge this
pawn
and so i said the word pawn break
so hopefully the move c5 stuck out to
some of you and hopefully the move e5
also stuck out to some of you these are
really just the two main ways you can
challenge this pawn
on d4
and after something like c5 let's just
pretend i'm able to do it
in white passes
if white tries to leave this pawn here
then we're going to be very happy to
capture
and after pawn takes of course white
still has a space advantage the pawn
does give him some extra space but now
it's not connected to the rest of the
pawns now it's an isolated queen pawn
and it's something i can use to attack
and target as a weakness it's not just
strictly an advantage for white
so that's why the pawn break is so good
and of course if white were to capture
after something like e5 or c5 then the
space advantage is gonna go away then
you know neither of us have any uh space
advantage in the center and it's gonna
be a lot more more even so
the the question remains uh which one do
you think i should be going for e5 or c5
and and why how do you sort of make this
decision
in this game it was actually a pretty
easy decision for me for one one big
reason there's one piece on the board
that makes this decision
a lot easier
yeah so that's one actually very very
important feature in the position
if i tried something like c5 here
my opponent is not obligated actually to
take or to leave this pawn here actually
by pushing this pawn forward i'm giving
up a lot of control over the d5 square
and i know in this specific instance
this bishop could take on b7 but
just statically if i ever try to push c5
i might have to worry about this move d5
when actually my space disadvantages is
only getting worse right
if i try taking this guy the white
pieces might sort of spring into action
and i could be running into some trouble
so as you pointed out
e5 would not run into that issue at
least immediately because it does gain a
tempo on the knight no time to play d5
if if the knight's attacked
but beyond that i sort of already uh
gave it away with some of the lines the
the reason why c5 doesn't make a lot of
sense here is because we did have to
give up our light squared bishop this
bishop is going to be a monster on this
diagonal if i play something like c5 and
ever allow it to just view
this long open diagonal best diagonal on
the board for that bishop um and and i
just can't counteract it i have no
bishop to challenge to challenge with
so whenever you have um sort of the
bishop pair disadvantage you're
missing one of your bishops that your
opponent has you have to be very very
aware of this bishop and you have to
make sure that you're able to stunt it
somehow either with your pawns with you
know one of your knights uh somehow
someway you have to be able to challenge
this bishop and i just would not be able
to do that after this move c5
so e5 is definitely what i was looking
at and i actually go ahead and just play
it immediately
if i tried to prepare it with something
like queen to c7 uh as you pointed out
having this attack the knight is
actually really really nice
sort of worried that after something
like knight to d3 i might not be able to
achieve e5 quite as comfortably again i
was worried about this move c5 sort of
coming or d5 coming through in some
instances
so e5 right away
my opponent actually chooses not to
capture and goes knight back to e2
and here i play knight b6 which is a
pretty serious mistake i was sort of
trying to be clever and keep the tension
in the center of the board for a little
while longer
and start routing my knight to a square
like d5 but it does turn out that this
move does more harm than good uh of
course i should just take a take on d4
here there's no reason not to and after
some exchanges
um black is going to be doing
just fine in this position i can
challenge this queen either with bishop
e5 maybe even bishop c5 could even
consider something like queen to f6 a
lot of different options here for for
black to continue
um instead though tried to be clever and
chose knight to b6
and julian does find a nice idea here
which i did anticipate but it's still
still a nice idea to be aware of there
is one way to always challenge knights
on b6 or b3 and oftentimes this also
happens with knights on g3 or g6
although
um i first learned the idea with with
knights on the b file like this there's
a really easy way to challenge these
knights and just make them look a little
bit silly
and the chat is discussing a move that
is about to come up so i will
answer those questions momentarily
so at first glance this knight seems
like it's it's totally fine here on b6
like i said i'm trying to target this d5
square a little bit
um but the problem is this is never
really going to be a stable square and
the reason for that is white can um sort
of target this knight with natural space
gaining moves so
uh in chess you know it can be tough to
push your pawns in the center a lot of
the time that's where all the the combat
is happening but especially with you
know alpha zero in the past few years
everybody loves throwing their rook
pawns forward and it turns out with the
knight on b6 throwing the roof pawn
forward is a very easy way to just make
this knight very very uncomfortable
now if i don't do anything white can and
will play this move a5
and maybe even follow up with a6 when
again i have to be very very careful not
to let this bishop into the game so a6
of course would undermine my light
squared defense here and this bishop
would start sort of cutting into the
position so a4 a nice idea
of course i had something in mind i just
play this move a5 to try and stop it so
what was the point of it all well now
this knight of course has no pawns
defending it so it's a little bit
unsteady and after the move um takes
takes and now queen b3
white is able to get this nice little
bit of pressure against my queen side
here now it's it's not a lot it's not
going to win the game right away but it
is a little bit uncomfortable for black
you have to be careful here not to let
something slip because if you make one
big mistake and you lose this b pawn
next thing you know the c pun is going
to fall as well and your queen side just
just collapses so
slight inaccuracies from me here and the
game sort of felt like it was getting
just a little bit out of hand
um in the game though
things are still going okay i just go
ahead and play this move queen to c7 and
i actually don't love how julian uh
continued here i thought for sure he was
just going to
try and
finish development somehow something
like even bishop e3 although it looks a
little bit scary with uh knight takes e3
but i thought he would go for
like bishop g5 uh something like this
rook d1 just continuing to bring the
pieces into the game
and eventually play for something like
c4 c5 maybe it's a little bit risky to
open up this diagonal for my bishop but
again he's going for this nice queen
side counter play and i thought there
were a lot of different ways he could do
that maybe even knight to f4 knight to
d3 knight to c5 these kinds of ideas to
help target my queen side
instead he went for this move bishop to
h3 and here i think is
my first super serious mistake of the
game so i did what's called believing
your opponent i believed in my
opponent's idea
so in chess whenever your opponent plays
a move that you don't expect it's always
a great idea to slow down
and take a moment and say okay i didn't
expect this move what on earth could my
opponent want why is my opponent moving
this bishop off the lung diagonal and
attacking my knight
so clearly he wants my knight to move
the question is why why does he want my
knight to move what's his intention
so what do you guys think what could his
intention be
yeah what do you think
bishop h6 wow so you are more on top of
things than i am i thought he was gonna
go bishop e3 so i started looking at
this bishop e3 idea
and i sort of became a little bit
concerned so my most natural move here i
thought was either knight g7 or knight
to d6 and the reason is after knight g7
i went ahead for this super stable
square on e6 knights do really well
on stable squares that are defended by
pawns even if they're not you know on
the sixth rank uh trying to attack and
uh trying to attack the opponent they
still do well on stable squares they can
control a large portion of the board and
especially on e6 it would be shutting
down this diagonal threatening to hop
into some uh pretty important squares
at a moment's notice and it would be
very very nice very nice to have there
and same thing with knight d6 with
knight d6
this is a reasonably stable square
the other knight can come to a square
like d5 and my knights together are just
going to control
large areas of the center if i'm able to
maintain this position
however against both of these moves i
thought that my opponent was intending
to go bishop to e3 and
okay i drew a lot of arrows bishop to e3
with the point being that it's targeting
my loose knight on b6
and i thought after this knight moved
this bishop might step into c5 all of a
sudden i have to move my rook and the
more i looked at it the more i just
became concerned
that uh he was going to be able to
invade on these dark squares somehow
it's going to give me a lot of a lot of
trouble on the dark squares maybe even
like knight c1 to d3 and these dark
squares are sort of falling to my
opponent's control
now it turns out that uh this stuff is
is pretty okay for for black it turns
out i was sort of seeing ghosts with
these uh these ideas on the dark squares
this bishop is actually a little bit
vulnerable something like knight to e6
would immediately target it for example
and black is is doing fine here uh you
know so
uh instead of this i came up with this
weird-looking move knight e7
now the reason for this is i wanted to
respond to bishop e3 with knight e to d5
and i felt like this was the way for me
to continue to keep all my dark squares
under control my knight can now help
defend b6 target this bishop on e3 and
after something like this
rookie 8 i'm immediately going to go
with knight to d7 and this bishop is
actually running out of squares
so i did play this move knight to e7 but
as you pointed out bishop h6 is also a
very reasonable idea and that is
actually what julian ends up playing
um
and because of these these ideas uh
because you know i believed my opponent
i put my knight on pretty
pretty much an objectively worst square
and that that gives julian an
opportunity here to to sort of take the
lead once again
now it turns out the bishop h6 actually
isn't the way to do it um as i've been
saying there is this really tempting
knight rerouting maneuver and this is
the way for for white to play for an
edge uh something like knight d5 for
example knight d3 bishop g7 knight c5
turns out this knight is just very very
strong on on this square and it's going
to give black some problems difficult to
to challenge this piece very effectively
you also don't have to play knight c5
right away you can do some other things
c4 c5 is also in the air
lots of ideas for white
but instead bishop h6 rookie 8 and rook
to e1
so
not all is lost my pieces are just a
little bit awkward and i do an okay job
of repositioning i do bring this knight
out to d5 we see this knight come to d4
i simply retreat back to f6 i'm
anticipating knight f3
we do see knight f3
and then i finally play this move knight
to d7 so
slowly but surely i'm reorganizing my
pieces to more active squares i have
this knight on a nice stable square on
d5 and things seem to be coming back
back into uh into my control
rook to d1 is played and then i very
concretely go okay first i go rookie
seven then after queen to e a3 uh here
very concretely i can simplify the
position just a little bit
so
uh i do that with this move knight to e5
which again is is still totally fine
we get a trade
by the way i'm making a threat don't
hang your bishops
my opponent doesn't i go queen h5
and now bishop to d2
and at this moment i felt like the the
tide was sort of turning you know my
opponent just had to retreat for two
moves in a row i got rid of that one of
my annoying knights my remaining knight
is on this nice d5 square where it's
reasonably stable of course i have to be
worried about c4 in some instances but
you know i've got control over this open
file my queen is active my bishop is
active my knight's on a good square i
felt like things were sort of turning in
in my direction
and this is where i make the the losing
losing move and this is why
i chose to go over this game here
because it's the sort of move that's
like so dumb it's like what am i going
to learn from you know this this super
simple mistake uh you know the answer is
just don't play you know stupid mistakes
that blunder your pieces but there is
something i think to take away from here
so the move i played in the game is rook
to e2
now let's see if you guys are good
enough to to beat me at chess here i get
the feeling some of you are
maybe all of you
what is the problem with rook to e2
and don't feel bad if you can't find it
here because this was a 90 30 game
you've got like 45 minutes to figure out
how to beat me now you don't have 45
minutes here tonight but if we were
playing a game you you certainly would
i think it comes to mind if the bishop
kills the knight and then you use the
other bishop to trap the rook i'm not
sure that'll actually work that's what
just comes quickly
yeah i wasn't so worried about this um i
think i can always extract extract the
rooks somehow
yeah brian
yeah that's exactly right so in the game
i obviously noticed that i was like hey
if bishop f3 ever happens i'm in i'm in
big trouble and then i i swear to you i
thought to myself thankfully there's no
bishop f3 tactics here i'm playing
rookie too uh of course there's a bishop
f3 tactic here as brian pointed out the
sneaky sneaky queen on a3 that i thought
i had banished to the queen's site that
was never going to give me problems
again
of course uh does control laterally the
f3 square after this move c4
and with that uh black is is dead lost
there's just nothing to do here there's
no way to save all your pieces and i'll
show you what what happens in a moment
but i do go on to lose the game of
course
so
what's the deal how do you you know take
anything away from you know blundering a
two-move tactic in your game
well the important thing is to be
brutally honest with yourself you know
it's very very easy to write off uh one
or two move blunders as
you know an unavoidable fact of chess
you're always going to blunder sometimes
nobody is immune to blunders certainly
not me and if you follow professional
tournaments every once in a blue moon
you'll see them blunders something
similar you know everybody is capable of
missing a two-move tactic
but oftentimes you can trace it back to
a mistake in your thinking process
so
the more i thought about this game the
more i realized that i had a pretty big
mistake in my thinking process you know
i was sort of
uh playing with the momentum of the game
you know you start feeling good your
opponent's pieces are heading backwards
your pieces are heading forwards
and i got into kind of a rhythm i was
like okay things are going well for me
i'm gonna you know keep going forward
try to invade try and start getting an
advantage with moves like like rook to
e2 uh start trying to make some threats
against the king
and uh start taking the initiative
and that's something you really do have
to look out for it's easy to get caught
up in the game when things seem to be
going well
i i find myself often times speeding up
i played rookie too reasonably quickly
and getting a little bit over optimistic
is what i've noticed
so that is
the big mistake that that i'm taking
away not that i hung a two move tactic
nobody's immune to two move tactics
but uh the mistake is in my thinking
process you know you wanna be careful
you've got to be diligent you cannot be
lazy at the board you have to ensure
that your moves are safe
so that is the big valuable lesson to
take away from this game uh
which again i'm going to show you the
rest you get to see how julian crushed
me
but uh that that's the point i'm trying
to get across even
from the stupidest mistakes two move
tactics one move blunders there there is
something to learn and oftentimes it is
in self-evaluating your thinking process
saying okay why did i end up blundering
here was it actually just you know
random chance my time was up to make a
big blunder or is there something i
should be doing differently at the board
some other way i should be thinking at
the board and that's the sort of
self-reflection that you really need if
you want to cut down on these blunders
cut down on these mistakes you have to
be looking at them have to be trying to
understand where they're coming from why
they're happening
okay so rook e2 c4
and then points to anybody in the chat
if you actually came up with the move
rook takes f2 before you played the move
c4 because i'm not going to go down uh
without a fight i'm going to go down
swinging so rook takes f2 uh hopefully
you were all well prepared for this and
saw everything far in advance how to
refute rook takes f2
so you're not done yet i haven't
resigned yet you still have work to do
to beat me at this chess game
so what can you come up with here
against rook f2 of course what's the
points if rick takes f2
what's my idea
no stronger than that this rook was
important here on f1
yeah queen takes rook is in the position
so
no i'm not without ideas not without
ideas
mr e in the chat says bishop f3 anyways
which loses to checkmates all right i'm
2-0 so far
2-0
so king takes rook is is going to be
really really scary uh now
now what i now what might i do
now so my queen is nice here i i can
sort of get him in a crisscross you guys
know the crisscross
pattern this is my friend chris
and this is my friend cross
and this king is is running out of
squares right bishop e3 i can take it um
and still supported by my knight king to
e1 you might actually be checkmated here
might actually be checkmated here
so you guys are eventually by the
process of elimination i think going to
arrive at at the move here
um and oftentimes this is a great
defensive resource when your opponent is
tac is attacking if you can remove one
of the attacking pieces sometimes the
attack is not so scary anymore
so with that hints what comes to mind
yeah you just take the knight with the
pawn the sort of the most natural move
uh does turn out to be correct here and
now without this knight i do not have
the necessary forces to control the e3
square and i'm running out of ideas
i do still have some ideas though i come
out with bishop to d4
and after bishop to e3 i do have this
nice little tactic rook takes g2 and
queen to e2 with check
again you cannot block with the rook
because i'll capture your other rook
uh and after bishop to f2 i do have
bishop takes f2 or take or bishop takes
f2 and if you go rick takes f2 i'm
actually winning with queen takes d1
again
but julian comes up with this nice move
queen to f3 and queen f3 wins queen d3
wins even queen b3 wins but he chooses
queen f3 so he navigates the the few
complications that i was able to throw
at him and we end up simplifying into
this end game
which is gonna be actually uh pretty
easily winning for white you might
expect that black can put up uh somewhat
of a fight here but with good play white
is just gonna be winning so there's one
more important move to play here before
i i call it quits on this game and just
you know say julian did the rest with
ease
so what do you play here with white to
firmly secure your advantage
there's a couple options
yep that's exactly right d6 here so when
you're pushing for the win oftentimes
it's incorrect to trade pawns and
especially when you have a strong pawn
that is passed uh it's a good idea to
push it you know i'm not the first
person to say this so d6 is
now just securing it a totally winning
advantage for white
and of course i fought on for a long
long time the game went something like
this
and then after g4 i stopped putting the
game into this leachate study so i was
very unhappy uh but what's the winning
idea for white here uh well of course
this rook is doing a great job of
pinning down the black rook to d8 strike
is not going to be able to move
otherwise queens is going to be strong
this rook prevents my king from helping
out and so all white needs to do now is
force a weakness on the king's side
which he does by pushing these pawns and
this rook can start invading over here
the king can start invading as well king
f4 king g5 ideas and that's exactly uh
what happens in the game just to show
some moves
something like this ended up happening i
think
um
let's see here i actually think i played
this uh very very silly move h6 h5 g5
and now um
now this king made its way in to f5 for
example
and things went downhill from here right
i tried something like b5 and i had
nearly swindled him but but was unable
to so from heropla you can see rookie
six and black's position is is becoming
pretty hopeless pretty quickly
uh so that's that game um i would say it
was my worst game in the tournament
um
but not necessarily because of just this
one blunder rook to e2 i think it's my
worst game in the tournament because of
these mistakes in my thinking process
that's something you can correct you
can't totally eliminate two move
blunders one move blunders from your
games but you can correct your thinking
process and that's that's the takeaway
when you play your worst games it's
still very important to look at them and
try and understand where these mistakes
are are coming from oftentimes it's not
just out of thin air there's a reason
that you're making mistakes
um so we spent a lot of time on this
game but do you guys have any questions
for me that was a lot to cover lots to
talk about so any questions
on this game the caro khan this line in
particular
what do you guys have for me
nothing i love it alright well let me do
a quick review then and then i want to
show you uh at least the start of one
other game
so how did we get here we played the
carol khan
once again my opponent surprised me with
this move knight g to h5 i think i
actually responded pretty well to the
surprise keeping things simple keeping
my position solid was a good idea
developing out avoiding castling until
my opponent does paying close close
attention in the opening when you get
surprised
then this e5 break is my attempt to
equalize
my b6 is a little bit inaccurate better
just again to keep things simple make
sure i'm equalizing
and then after this my next mistake
believing my opponent too much worried
about bishop e3 i should just play the
natural moves either knight g7 or knight
d6
then after this i play like a genius i'm
able to i think almost fully equalize
with these ideas and then blunder it all
away with rookie two because i got a
little bit too careless felt a little
bit too confident in my position uh had
to stay vigilance had to make sure i
didn't blunder and then the rest of the
game is is the rest of the game
uh mr e asks how did i place an attorney
i won the tourney as you would know if
you followed i think last week or two
weeks ago i'm not sure lost track of
time
okay
with that i want to show you the start
of a game that i won which i forgot to
put the names in but this is my game
against uh arjun puri who is a very very
strong uh young kid in st louis who i
think now uh gains like 70 rating points
in this tournament he's around 20 70
rated i'm sure he will be crushing me
before too long but in this game i have
the white pieces against him
i start out with d4 d5 c4 c6 i take he
takes
and i choose this move knight to c3 now
arjun is a very hard-working kid and i
think he was at the time taking lessons
with julian who again knows my entire
repertoire so i'm in trouble
uh normally i play this move bishop f4
but i knew that arjun knew that so you
know in classic princess bride style i
deviated first played this move knight
to c3
because i knew that he knew but then
that he knew that i knew that he knew
and then all right knight c3
uh
and arjun immediately messes up the move
order which is a weakness i sort of
noticed in in arjun's opening play i i
don't think he has his move orders quite
correct here so he chooses knight to c6
the better move here for black is simply
knight to f6
now the reason for that is knight to c6
does not defend the e4 square and this
move e4 can get uh pretty tricky for
black if you're not familiar with it
so i go e4 arjun plays d takes e4 i go
d5 knight e5
i had seen all this beforehand queen a4
check takes
takes on e4
and takes on g6
so so far so good
i had looked at this all beforehand and
i knew that this was like plus two for
white i was like this position is great
i'm very very close to winning already
this could not have gone better uh
however i did not know the next move
because you know you have to
uh economize your time when you're
prepping for a tournament you don't want
to spend all your time looking at the
winning positions in case they actually
play the good moves but in this case
arjun unfortunately fell into this
opening trap and i just have a very very
good position here and already this is
my first mistake of the game
so put yourself in my shoes here you
know you have a very good position your
position should be very very strong
and so what do you do you know your
position is good you just don't know
which move it is to win what are you
thinking about when you find yourself in
that spot
this is from master lab right yes
what to do
and you can either give me a move or
even just sort of uh a way of thinking
you know we're talking about fixing our
thinking process tonight
uh looking at our bad games to try and
do that
so should i try to kill the guy should i
just try to like win out of the opening
and plus two you've made too many
mistakes now's my time
or should i maybe keep it simpler what
do you think
yeah so i think that this was my mistake
i thought that my position was so good
and i found a very very tempting move
and i thought maybe this move is the
reason why black's position is so bad
and i can just kind of win directly
but as always simple chess is oftentimes
the best chess and developing normally
would have been really really great here
so
knight to f3 is what the chat was
suggesting which is a totally fine move
but there is actually another way to
develop that makes black's life a little
bit harder so i'm looking at this bishop
in particular this bishop's undeveloped
and i can keep it undeveloped if i play
play one correct move here
so with that in mind what do you think
is
the right way to go
bishop g5 okay so not necessarily
although this move does certainly look
interesting
um so bishop g5 the point is you're
targeting this e pawn and you're trying
to make it so this e pawn can't move and
this bishop has to stay on f8
uh but in this instance i think knight
f6 is going to be a very natural move
for black
and
if you take i think i am not too unhappy
about actually playing g takes when i'm
going to develop to g7 and at least get
castled now i'm not saying black is
doing well here but black is at least
you know making it out of the opening
giving the pieces in the game
um and of course if you move the queen
um
up to you what's square to be honest i'm
not sure maybe the e3
now e6 i do think would would be getting
played um
and not to say that this is ideal i
think i'm probably taking this with the
f pawn and playing bishop b7 of course
white's going to be a little bit better
but
white can can play even stronger in this
position
there's an even more concrete way to
keep this pawn from moving
that's exactly right just bishop c4 you
develop a piece you get your king closer
to castling and you stop e6 it does
everything you could ever want in a
chess move you play e6 now i'm simply
just attacking this guy too many times
there's no
tricks
because i can just save my bishop and
you you have lost
uh same thing here
i can even take this with check now free
pawn for white uh lead in development
clearly uh winning
so bishop c4 would have been really good
now the chat room has been shouting out
knight b4 which is highly illegal but
knight b5 is what i played in the game
so
you know i i got i got drawn into the
the thrill of it you know i'm
threatening checkmate
on like move nine this is great
uh and i thought that this might be why
my opponent's position was was so bad
and i actually played knight b5 fairly
quickly and if you're noticing a theme
when i think things are going well i
seem to play uh play very aggressive
moves and not put quite enough thought
into them so remember that last game
that i played against julian that went
horribly for me maybe if i had looked at
that game earlier
before my game against arjun i would
have thought to slow down a little bit
keep things a little bit more simple and
be a little bit more cautious even
though things are going well have to be
cautious i think that's the the takeaway
for me from this tournament from my
worst games at least
so i go knight b5 my opponent now plays
e6 with impunity
um i take on e6 we see bishop takes e6 i
think f takes e6 is supposed to be
marginally better but it's all okay
and now i look and i look and i look i
look at this move
i look at
you know stupid moves
uh and i can't find a win so i play
bishop to d2 which turns out to be a
totally fine move
and now my opponent does give me
does give me another chance turns out
bishop c5 i think is the best way for
black to continue
just get these pieces in the game get
developed as soon as you can and you
will survive the opening instead he
chose this move queen to e7 which is a
very concrete move it's trying to get
the queens off the board say
i see how your pieces are lined up if i
can get a queen trade i'm going to be
able to develop i'm going to make it out
of the opening
but this move loses immediately
uh
so we've got a few minutes see if you
can find out how to just immediately win
the game
i was unable to find it in the game of
course
and just to give you some idea of how
winning it is i think the engine reads
something like plus 10 here so it's it's
pretty good it's pretty good for white
pretty strong
pretty strong position
um the chat says bishop c4 this one
actually loses a piece
your queen is pinned
actually i guess you have knight d6
there
but then king d7
yeah i don't know bishop c4 is kind of
weird but not the idea
um and james in the chat does have the
idea but we'll give
we'll give people a little bit longer to
think about it
wow james just putting me to shame just
finding it in like 30 seconds
i couldn't find it over the board
shameful
shameful
the night
yeah it is a good question
that's what i was thinking in the game
it's like where do i put this piece
yeah now maybe d6 yes so
this is the trap that i fell into in the
game i was like oh knight c7 is so so
tempting i want to get this night out i
want to bring this bishop in i want to
bring my other bishop in bring my rook
in i want to check me at the guy this is
this is my plan
and i got so enamored with knight to c7
that i you know i sat there i spent like
uh i think 10 minutes or so just like
thinking you know knight c7 knight c7
knight c7 knight c7
um and i got stuck thinking of all these
lines and it turns out knight c7 doesn't
work uh and i came to that conclusion in
the game um knight c7
black is just going to take this piece
you go bishop b5 check um i think black
just runs in this direction
and i didn't see i i just didn't see the
follow up here i didn't see how you were
supposed to to get from this to a
winning position for example something
like this
knight f6
rick d1
um
okay i was going to say king here but
now i'm realizing that this might happen
is that working for white all right
we're going to cheat because time is low
um bishop g5 knight f6 rook d1
king c8 is enough or just bishop to d6
okay
and we are somehow someway
having all of our pieces into the game
uh and protecting the king it's like
minus six here says says stockfish so
i'm not totally crazy
um so knight c7 no good and so
eventually i came to my senses i was
like all right knight c7 is no good i'm
going to develop my pieces and play rook
c1 now of course knight to d6 is just
completely winning uh what's the
difference the difference is that after
king to d8
the queen is not defending the a5 square
and bishop a5 check is just entirely
winning you can't even block with b6
because your rook on a8 hangs with check
you come this way simplest is rook to d1
when rip to d8 is a tough threat to stop
very very tough
um
and knight d6 just just wins on the spot
so again
you know
you can chalk it up to okay sometimes
you you miss the tactic but again it's a
mistake in the thinking process you have
to make sure you're calculating
effectively and efficiently don't spend
all your time you know on one move and
then just give up
you know when something doesn't feel
like it's working it's worth it to take
a step back
go back to the start and say is there
you know something easier something
easier here but instead i miss it i go
rook to c1 my opponent plays knight to
f6
and again
uh i was i just missed a two move tactic
here and this was one of those times
where i honestly could not tell you what
the mistake in the thinking process was
because i was staring at this move
knight to c7 i was staring at this move
queen to c7 in my brain and i was just
like there's nothing to do here there's
just there's no way to do it i just
can't do it this just doesn't work when
obviously queen takes e6 with check is
just getting a big advantage for white
if you take
i take if you block
i check and you run into a lot of the
same problems
and here white is just gonna be
significantly better with with the rook
invading
now for whatever reason i couldn't find
that i brought my queen back to e2 and
then arjun played like a genius because
he is one
um played all the best moves played all
the best moves all the best moves by
arjun
knight g5 all the best moves by origin
knight to e7 knight f3 castles castles
um g6 and up to g6 arjun has seriously
been been playing like a genius
and here i actually would have been
worse if you found this move bishop to
f5 now all of a sudden these bishops are
raking down the board my rook on c1 is
actually a little bit awkwardly placed
to do something to protect my pawn and
bishop b2 i'm sort of running out of
squares here it's not so comfortable for
me uh in this position in particular so
from plus 10 to slightly worse in a
matter of a few moves there
so again not so good now i did end up
winning this game but only because arjun
made a one-move mistake which it's up to
him to determine his thinking process up
to this point again he's been playing
very very well then he just randomly
plays this move king to f8 which of
course allows white to take the
advantage uh after knight h7
king g7
knight f6 when black loses i think the
most important piece on the board
in exchange for the knight now things
just collapse from here knight takes f6
is a big mistake bishop b2 and there's
just no way to to escape from from this
pin
uh knight's
g8 knight g5 he does escape but it costs
him a pawn
and now my bishop pair is is going to go
ahead and and win the game and the rest
of the game is is not so eventful
um i do go on to win here eventually i
trade down into this end game
and then he offers to go into this end
game which for the first time in my life
i actually did calculate correctly even
better than the lead chess computer
which calls this a blunder
because this king and pawn end game is
is just winning um and if you give the
engine long enough it'll find it as well
so if you want to that's your homework
solve this king and pawn end game why is
it winning how is it winning but
unfortunately we are out of time for
tonight we do have the wonderful
katarina nemkova coming in directly
after me make sure you stick around for
that it's going to be a great lecture
and i want to thank you all very much
for joining me here tonight so as always
my name is caleb denby this has been the
road to 2000 and i will see you guys
next time
[Music]
you